the other thing i was gonna say is uh
you know the the
the thing about the trump uh
raid at mar-a-lago
it being so galvanizing to me it was
like
i've seen this happening over and over
again to private citizens in the united
states that's what my whole movie is
about and a month ago 6 22 of this year
a woman called me and told me about a
raid that happened at her house
this is like 19 months after january 6th
the fbi storms into her ranch
her and her husband are asleep it's the
middle of the night
they see they have security on their
gate because the
both her and her husband are security
people they they
you know trained in weaponry and stuff
they they they provide security
and
they see people at their gates and she
says this isn't a deer honey there's
people out there and all of a sudden
they just break down the gates they come
barreling down their driveway
swat teams
they're you know throwing flash bangs at
them come out of your house with your
hands up and they're screaming where's
the warrant
what what are you here for
basically they terrorized them they
handcuffed them there's a rental
property on their same ranch they
flashbanged that they said thank god the
the person that rented there wasn't home
but they they they just basically
handcuffed these this couple out on
their lawn pull the vehicles around
their house so that they couldn't see
what they were doing and went inside for
six hours and ransacked their house
and all the time they're saying what are
you here for
where's the warrant they go we'll show
you when we're good and ready whatever
they said and he finally says what are
you looking for and he says we have a
picture of you says this to the husband
we have a picture of you
attacking a police officer
on january 6 inside the building he said
i never went in the building show me the
picture he says no i will show it to you
later he says
i want to see the picture and he shows
him this blurry picture
he says that's that could be anybody
that's not me i didn't that's not me
and finally after this is all over they
he said where's the warrant one last
time and they said we left it on the
couch and they go in and they look at
the warrants on the couch and it says
they were looking for three items
a trump beanie a trump gator and a puffy
black coat
three articles of clothing
and they terrorize these people in this
way
so why do they do that
what is the point of doing that
it's it it's there's no justice involved
there's three articles of clothing and
fairly common items yeah i mean any
that's that's like
i was there everybody had a puffy coat
and like a trump hat on i mean
this is not just happening to trump it's
happening to normal people it's why i'm
been obsessive lately another reason of
this pardon why i think a mass pardon is
on the horizon because it's like this
black blackstone's formula man it's like
it's echo been echoing in my
consciousness it's better that we let a
thousand guilty people go than somebody
has to sit in prison that's innocent
i i
i don't know about the
you know to what extent we could do
pardon because i would not agree with
like
you know hunter biden being part or
anything like that but i will say that i
think we took a wrong turn when this
country decided that we should hand off
our responsibility towards personal
protection to external governmental
agencies
so it used to be the communities were
self-policing the local militia would
take care of their local issues and
there was a duly elected sheriff and
maybe a deputy
nowadays cities all have their own
departments where they've monopolies on
how to deal with with these issues and
depending on how big the city is it gets
worse and worse for instance in new york
where you can't have a gun you can't
defend yourself violating the
constitution and your rights i think
maybe the issue should just ultimately
go back to you know what
if uh we you know we need law
enforcement and your judicial system for
probably property crimes to deal with
resolving those things but in terms of
you know any other kind of violent crime
or robbery
i think two-way takes care of all that
stuff
polite armed societies applied society
people should have their right to
protect themselves and we should restore
responsibility to the greatest degree we
can to the individuals and so you know
i'm mentioning that in terms of the
pardoning of people perceived as being
violent i'm kind of like yeah you know
what
if someone is convicted duly and it's
proven they've done this beyond a
reasonable doubt by a jury of their
peers by all means
you know they've gone through due
process they can be deprived of their
rights and locked up but for the most
part i'm kind of like
you know we don't need all these cops we
don't need to be dealing with this this
prison system if people were just armed
like second amendment prescribes
yep well you got to protect
vigilantes
someone with a gun being like i thought
they were invading my house i didn't
know like that's a big problem that's
why that's property crimes right that's
why we do need some kind of system but i
think duly elected law enforcement i'm
talking about we shouldn't be worried
about walking down the street no we
should have local law enforcement as the
first
the first gate for sure and that should
even protect you from federal law
enforcement that's gone overboard or
state law enforcement's just gone
overboard as your local law enforcement
and if there are none then you have to
take it on your own shoulders that's
what happened to these people that i was
just talking about they reached out to
the sheriff
to say you know
these these people the fbi why were you
allowing them to violate our rights this
way and the sheriff's job should have
been to step in and protect them but he
he wouldn't do anything why
well i don't know i mean i guess he was
afraid i don't know why did he know
about it he knew about it after the fact
you know and and they asked him for help
and because what happens to these people
most of the time is that these break-ins
happen and i've talked to a lot of
people that this happened to the fbi
comes and terrorize them then breaks
down their door and does whatever they
do and then they just never hear from
them again
do you think
they were sitting there waiting for
charges they hire a lawyer charges never
come the lawyer tells them to be quiet
don't say anything because you know we
don't know what the fbi is going to do
so it just kind of puts a hush over
everything and and these people are just
sitting there waiting for the next shoe
to drop
kind of thing where like if they leave
the country just on a vacation that they
could get charged for as a flight thing
right you can't get charged for leaving
that's the thing about trump's passports
too i think it's a really weird sign
because you're right he wasn't charged
yeah you can leave i mean
they'll say you know don't leave but you
can't tell you what to do you can leave
unless they charge you i think they say
sometimes like when you leave it makes
you look more guilty like they try to
scare you into not going anywhere
because they can't tell you not to go
but they say like well but in court
it'll make like it'll look like you left
the country on this grand conspiracy or
whatever i was going to ask you if you
feel like local law enforcement for the
most part feels like they have to see
jurisdiction to the federal government i
mean from what i know which is very
limited on how law enforcement works
often it becomes once the federal
government has you know whether it be
uh you know the fbi or whatever that
once they get involved with something
they
you know have jurisdiction they are
allowed to take the lead on whatever
case they want often to the detriment
local law enforcement also feels like
that hurts some of the cases they're
working on
well
it varies sheriff to sheriff you know
the sheriff is the local law enforcement
that's elected by those people and you
have strong winds and you have weak ones
do you think if we had more like a
better understanding of federalism and
like the individual governments of state
people would feel like they could hold
their elected sheriffs accountable to
opposing the the fbi yeah and a lot of
the people who run for sheriff run on
that platform
you know we're going to protect your
second amendment rights we're going to
make sure that you know the federal
government can't come in and take your
weapons but then when it happens
they're intimidated and they don't they
don't do anything yeah
do you think in some ways it's because
they
you know i just think about all the um
some of the code regulations and
questions about like if you get uh money
through medicare or medicaid you have to
enforce the things the federal
government has said i wonder if it works
in the same way with law enforcement
they aren't sure what pressure is being
going to be put on them so they just
don't act at all you know yeah i'm sure
it's like that it's like the educational
system too
you know there was so much federal money
tied to
mass mandates and to
vaccine mandates that the the school
systems in order to get that federal
money they decided that they have to
comply
i mean this is how we got the drinking
age to where it is right they held the
the highway funding hostage until
everyone would agree to make it 20 21.
yeah thank god they did that you know
after i had already had my phone
where did you grow up
north carolina okay because there were
north carolina was one of the last
holdouts or maybe with south carolina i
can't remember the story completely but
i remember them being like no problem
federalism we love it except
we aren't going to give you any money
for your highways unless you comply i
mean they got really straight they got
shanghaied into doing exactly what the
federal government wants which i think
is how for the most part you know so
much of this happens i can only imagine
what it's like to be a part of local law
enforcement that you know worries what
kind of funding they're going to get if
they say no when they already know
you know from my understanding most
local law enforcement is understaffed
anyways yeah
well sheriff villanova in los angeles
county is really one of the better ones
he's he's been doing a really good job
at standing up to some of the mask
nonsense and all the the federal
mandates there
but it it just varies yeah place to
place when you were working on your
movie was like the role of local law
enforcement in the investigation did it
come up a lot in which in your uh movie
on january 6 your documentary
well no because mostly what we wound up
focusing on is the stories of people who
you know were there on january 6th and
who didn't really do anything wrong or
violent and who subsequently got visited
and persecuted and some of whom are put
in jail and none of them said i wish my
local sheriff had stepped in or did they
feel like
their state law enforcement didn't have
anything to do with well it all happened
so suddenly you know it these things
just come they they come at 5 30 in the
morning six in the morning right
there's no warning
a lot of these people never have been
arrested for anything before in their
lives and in that case you would expect
like a phone call you would expect them
to say we'd like to talk to you there
but instead they just just stand we do
it we do have an update that actually uh
came out just before we started the show
so uh apologies for not seeing this uh
sooner this was posted by kyle cheney of
politico
the trump team is publicizing this email
which shows the doj obtained three
passports two expired not one as trump
said no trump said oh okay trump said
was expired and alerted trump's lawyers
they were recovered by a filter team
which weeds out privileged info trump
publicized this after dog offered them
doj offered them back oh interesting so
yes but i don't think that
means anything that last point like
donald trump learned that they took his
passports and then complained they took
my passports right so the email says
evan jim we have learned the filter
agent sees three passports belonging to
president trump to expire one being his
active diplomatic passport we are
returning them and they will be ready
for pickup at wfo at 2pm today i am
traveling but you can coordinate further
with redacted copied above thanks
so it looks like they did take his
passports and it was the the accident
narrative i suppose and trump was
correct when he said they took them
and um
i don't know why it matters that trump
publicized it after after they offered
them back i mean i feel like they're
trying to say like he's so petty they
offered to give him back but it's like
why did they take them in the first
place yeah exactly i don't think that
that's her i mean i think you'll for the
rest of the week we'll see that a lot
well they offer to give it back
it's not that big a deal
but it is it's a huge deal yeah is
active diplomatic passport are you
kidding me they just like stumbled
across it we're like we don't know what
this is so we'll just take it with us
and it's active can he
as a former president can he still use a
diplomatic passport i i guess he can
right
scroll down to the the email again it
says active in there i think no it does
it does but i'm wondering can a former
president use a diplomatic passport yeah
i don't know i mean if it he must be
able to use it otherwise it wouldn't be
active is all i can say to that i i
think that i guess right right it must
be privileges for a while i mean i don't
know i'm not as well versed in what what
privileges are extended to the process
like what is it like if you're in
congress you retain your security passes
for life or something like that is how
it works
but there are extensions like and to a
certain extent he's still a
political figure of the united states i
mean he still travels quite a bit and is
a representation of the country
i can only see it there's some
explanation as to why they'd have it
it's such an unprecedented time you know
it's like he's not being treated like
any former president of the united
states he's being treated like a
criminal so
i don't know this is i was just thinking
our legal system the main purpose is to
protect the innocent that is why we
built it that's why we have it in place
it is not to find and destroy guilt or
evil it is to protect innocent people if
someone as a byproduct of the protection
of the innocent is charged
then that's that happens but
it should be that way yes i don't know
if it's ever if it's always cannot
function any other way otherwise it
becomes a self-persecuting immolation a
lot of it is retribution that's problem
that's a problem that's when societies
consume themselves as with restrictions
there's 500 people are more in jail in
dc right now most of them have not even
been interested in people because until
they're proven guilty they are innocent
right but they're they're hold they've
been holding them for over 18 months
with no charges no charges yeah and one
of them there i was told by somebody a
friend of his he's there because he saw
something
that happened with roseanne boylan one
of the women who died on january 6th he
saw what happened there and they don't
want him telling what he saw so he can't
write a letter
i don't know i'm just telling you but if
you're just reporting what i was told i
don't know if any of this is if you're
in prison they're controlling yourself
you know it's like you you you start
kind of trying to look for any kind of
conspiracy theory any kind of
explanation for why they would hold
somebody without charges for 18 months
it does doesn't make any sense there
must be some reason
well i'm not a fan of that
i should say it's exactly what they say
a lot of
law enforcement does to people of color
who are uh held on bad charges and are
not fairly treated it's you know
it always bothers me that there's no
consistency applied if you believe in
criminal justice reform you should
believe in it for everybody but it's
just this is worth overlooking i guess
yeah moral logic isn't the strong point
of the of the left
um that's one of the reasons not a fan
of the death penalty is that often
people say it's just retribution and i'm
like i don't know what is served through
retribution you know i've seen more than
enough movies comics anime you name it
cartoons where the the protagonist
explains revenge never makes the pain go
away it never solves the problem
i think it was even even batman
explained at one time
so i see these stories and it's just
like families you know i was told by
someone
when those families don't get the the
the
you know the justice of watching the
person who you know committed the crime
being put to death or whatever i'm like
i don't know if retribution
is going to solve anything for us or
just an eye for an eye makes the whole
world blind you know thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you